le nouveau data center situé à
aubergenville est sorti de terre
un projet mené par l'entreprise these
datacenter un investissement de 10
millions d'euros pour ce site de 6400
mètres carrés de surface au sol
il pourra accueillir jusqu'à 400 b ces
grandes armoires composée de serveurs
informatiques
on saura quasiment avec 8 cage et avec
dans cette salle de 150 bus informatique
danse 250 me informatique
on peut imaginer qu'il y ait deux mille
3000 serveurs informatiques
deux salles de ce type ont été
construites sur ce site une
infrastructure alimenté par un groupe
électrogène pour refroidir ces deux
espaces un système a été installé tout
leur foi et souffler dans le faux
plancher essor à des endroits où il ya
des dalles perforé sont des éléments qui
sont noirs là bas qui permettent à l'air
de sortir les autres sur les avants des
serveurs informatiques
these datacenter une entreprise 100%
française spécialisée dans le service
d'hébergement de serveurs numériques
avec une stratégie par rapport à
l'implantation à aubergenville on peut
accueillir des petits clients en
colocation qui vont prendre simplement
une baie ou 2b et accueillir des
les clients moyens dans des cages
privatives et ensuite des grands clients
qui peuvent être des éditeurs de
logiciels les gens du cac40 du top 100
français et qui vont prendre un quart de
sa lune de miel voir un bâtiment complet
parle notre actionnariat qui est 100%
français on vise les organismes publics
un deuxième bâtiment pourrait être
opérationnel dès 2023 à terme six
datacenters seront construits ici
sur les trente mille mètres carrés de
terrain